I shot that thing myself but what I was
gonna say but your kid is that I used to
come to your house and he was like in a
little adult what's up Bobby how are you
you know like he was like a cool kid
he's not weird or anything he's like
Huey and then I remember like you being
kind of strict with them like go do your
homework you know he's like all right
you know but like you know it's he's a
good dad yeah which is weird why because
there are some stories from that making
I mean I miss past
I just went cuz I cuz I look at him as a
comedian right yeah and he's childlike
you're sour we both are I know you're
not like al magical more your morgue
attendant imaginable when you talk to
him you're like say yeah he's at that
same urn he's a dad even renas is he
he's a dad you yeah he's like baby
really yeah are you and you have stuffed
animals behind you right I'll tell you
why because you and I are the kite type
of people yeah I went to your house you
poured money on my head $22,000 what do
you do though just shut the [ __ ] up all
right homey $22,000 in a bag you see the
bucket like it like it yeah like I have
a money what about Buffalo I'll examine
I'm gonna take it buddy trough for my
money Buffalo like a little trough like
its water I think he goes look what I
made on my merch are you kidding me
relax
it's [ __ ] funny relax right and you
pour it on my head we're a leveled
laughing you know me I got this guy's a
dad
man I want to spy for a money bucket
you're gonna have to try and sell you
know when you look I look at guys like
you and Sebastian you know me and he's
he was on the Forbes you know list right
bring it up he doesn't want to talk
about it but people already [ __ ] know
that you have money yeah yeah you know I
make fun of Gabriel Lacey he has a lot
of [ __ ] money
yeah Millions yeah people know that
already
it's common knowledge it's not you work
for it you deserve it
yeah why is your eyes clawed right now
you really angry when did you get that
done I got it my first big check which
means you were dropping dreaming about
it I was yo I was angry wait what were
you teeth like a bad mom have you seen
Chiclets or a candy cane you seen my
teeth I never looked at your teeth went
wow that's weird
no they were bad they were yeah cuz
Pablo has two and I had one tooth that
was fused up to the top of my jaw that's
still called a job here what is it up
here this is a jaw what's this upper gum
upper gums well then that's what it was
that was used in to that that bone
because I fell on a rock when I was a
kid huh
Oprah gum that sounds fine okay I didn't
know what it was called I didn't I
wasn't questioning him yeah Bobby but um
Pablo has his done yeah there's crack
residue on it no I'm not gonna laugh at
that he's doing better now someone's
struggling yeah I just threw a joke I'm
just kidding just kidding there's no
residue
everyone's so sensitive as of late okay
all I'm doing is speaking the truth my
friends and you guys are like oh I don't
want I don't care I don't know you know
this and that
we're taking a knee see something right
here yeah I speaking our minds yes we're
taking a knee what we're doing with NFL
players are doing yes however we're
we're exercising our right to speak
what's on our mind am I not right white
man come on Jason right yeah and none of
you guys are gonna stop me well yeah he
took a knee but he chose to put the knee
up
[Music]